مشاهدينا في هذا اللقاء الذي نجريه مع
المفوض العام لوكاله غوث وتشغيل اللجين
الفلسطينيين الانرو والسيد فيليب لازاريني
الذي ينضم الينا في وقت اننا نتحدث عن حرب
دخلت شهر الثاني 30 يوما من العمليات
العسكريه والقصف المتواصل من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه خلف ذلك
ماسي انسانيه وعدد كبير من الشهداء
والجرحى والنازحين الاونروا من ابرز
الوكالات والمنظمات الدول التي ترصد ما
يجري على الارض والتي تعرضت في حد ذاتها
الى هذه الاغارات الجويه ولوضع الانساني
المتا ازم في قطاع غزه سيد فيليب اهلا بك
ونبدا من هذا الامر وهو قصف مدارس ومراكز
ايواء تابعه للاونروا كيف تعلقون على
ذلك شكرا
للاستضافه كما
اشرت
ليس هناك مكان امن في غزه حاليا هناك 700
ال شخص الان ياون في مدارس او منشات
اونروا منذ بدايه الصراع اكثر من 50 من
هذه المنشات قد قصفت وهذا ادى الى
قتل الالاف من الاشخاص واصابه الالاف قبل
بضعه ايام كنت في غزه رت احد اماكن
الايواء واحد الناس قالوا لي ان هناك 80
اصابه
و خاصه في هذه الظروف التي نرى فيها
ازدحاما في اعداد الناس وانا صعقت
بسبب مشاهده الاطفال الذين كانوا يطلبون
الماء ويطلبون الغذاء ساعود الى هذه
الجزئيه وهو تصريح لافت كان لك عقب زيارتك
هذه ولكن قبل ذلك لاعود بك الى الارقام
كان لديكم تقرير عرض في الخامس من نوفمبر
عن عدد النازحين عدد القتلى ومن ضمنهم
كوادر تعمل في الاونر نريد ان تذكرنا بهذه
الارقام طاقم
الاونور يدفع ثمنا باهظا غير مسبوق لحد
اليوم هناك 88 شخصا من زملائنا قتلوا وهذا
امر مروع لهذه الوكاله هؤلاء الزملاء كما
تعلمون كانوا ممرضين واطباء ومعلمين وانا
اقول لزملائي
انهم كان بامكانهم ان يكونوا في سلام وامن
لو كانوا في منطقه غير غزه
الامن والسلام يغيبان عن قطاع غزه السييد
فيليب منذ السابع من اكتوبر وعمليات القصف
والغارات التي تشن من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تستهدف بشكل اساسي وواضح وفق
كل ما نغطيه على الارض منشات مدنيه وكما
ذكرنا على راسها مدارس ومراكز ايواء
للاونروا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقول بان
هذه المراكز وهذه المدارس تضم في جنباتها
عناصر من المق الفلسطينيه كيف
ترد
ل
ان الاعداد مذهله جدا ونحن نتحدث اليوم عن
تقريبا 100 الا شخص قتلوا ونتحدث عن 5000
طفل
قتلوا اذا فهذا يعتبر اعلى عدد
في هذا
الصراع وهذا اعلى من كل الاعداد للاطفال
الذين قتلوا منذ مده طويله اذا لا يمكن
لهذه الاعداد ان تكون اضرارا جانبيه وليس
هناك تكافؤ الان في القيام بهذه الحرب
ولهذا السبب فنحن كانرى والامم المتحده
نناشد وباستمرار من اجل ان يكون هناك هدنه
انسانيه ا الهدنه الانسانيه يتم الحديث
عنها كثيرا وضمن ايضا الاضرار الانسانيه
الكبيره والكارثه وفقا تصنيف عدد من
المنظمات الدوليه هو عدم وصول المساعدات
والاحتياجات الى المحتاجين اليها ومن
ضمنهم الناز النازحون الى المراكز ومدارس
الاونروا كيف يبدو الوضع فيما يتعلق
باحتياجات
هؤلاء
نحن بحاجه الى وقف لاطلاق النار على اساس
انساني لوقف القصف العشوائي الذي يجري
الان وراينا ان المدنيين لم يتم مراعاه
كونهم مدنيين ولا المستشفيات ولا مقرات
الامم المتحده ولا اي مكان اخر لذلك فنحن
بالتالي بحاجه الى خدنه انسانيه لنضمن
اننا نحن كعاملين في مجال الاغاثه
الانسانيه ان نتمكن من الوصول الى منهم
بحاجه الى هذه المساعدات في قطاع غزه سواء
كان الشخص في مدينه غزه او في المنطقه
الجنوبيه ولكن الواقع هو اننا بحاجه الى
هدنه انسانيه وذلك بغيه ان يكون هناك
مساعدات انسانيه تقدم بشكل اكبر على مدى
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه كان هناك عدد من
الش الشحنات القادمه ولكن هذا يعتبر اقل
بكثير جدا مما هو لازم ومطلوب الان وقد
رايت هذا بنفسي عندما ذهبت الى غزه هناك
نقص في كل شيء نقص في الطعام ونقص في
المياه ونقص في الوقود وكل هذه الحاجات
الانسانيه الاساسيه يجب ان يتم ادخالها
لانني اؤمن بانه فورا الناس قد يبداون ب
الموت باعداد كبيره بسبب الحصار وليس فقط
ب بسبب ما يجري الان ولكن بسبب القصف ما
هي تقديرات سيد فيليب للاحتياجات التي يجب
ان تدخل لهؤلاء النازحين والمحتاجين بحيث
تحدث
فرقا نحن نتحدث عن المياه والطعام بشكل
اساسي عندما التقيت النازحين في مدرسه في
رفح الطلب الرئيسي كان منهم نرجوكم قدموا
لنا المياه وقدموا لنا رغيف خبز اذا فنحن
بالتالي علينا ان نبدا بتلبيه الحاجات
الاساسيه ولكن الواقع هو ان الناس الان
يعيشون في ظروف مروعه للغايه
هناك مدارس
ومقار كلها
مزدحمه
بالناس وبدون اي مياه تقدم للناس
واجراءات الاصحاح ايضا مقلقه وايضا نحن
نشير الى ان غياب
الوقود امر مروع
فالوقوع يعني المياه ويعني تشغيل
المستشفيات والمخابز وتقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه والتحرك لكي يكون هناك وصول
للناس المجين وبدون الوقود لن نكون قادرين
ابدا على ان نستجيب للحاجات الانسانيه
الملحه لهؤلاء الناس هذه الاحتياجات التي
اشرت اليها سيد فيليب عندما تطالبون بها
ما الردود التي تاتيكم خاصه كما ذكرت انها
جزء اساسي من شريان حياه هؤلاء
النازحين انا اعتقد وامن انه كان هناك بعض
التقدم ولكننا ما زلنا بعيدين جدا عن ما
هو مطلوب بدانا قبل اسبوعين ب 20 شاحنه
وهذا يعتبر نقطه في البحر واقول ان هذا
يعتبر فتاتا في واقع الامر ولا يستجيب
لحاجات الناس الملحه ولن يؤدي الى اثر
ايجابي يعكس اثار الحصار السلبيه اليوم
وانا اذكركم دائما هناك حاجه ملحه بان
يكون هناك تدفق للبضائع بحيث تدخل الى
قطاع غزه لكي نضمن ان الناس لا يتضورون
جوعا ولا يموتون بسبب الجوع او بسبب
انعدام المياه قبل السابع من اكتوبر قطاع
غزه والذي وصف بانه خاضع للحصار كان
يستقبل 500 شاحنه يوميا اليوم
هناك حاجه ملحه اكبر مما كان عليه الحال
قبل السابع من اكتوبر ولكن الشاحنات التي
تدخل هي قليله جدا ولذلك هناك حاجه ملحه
لزياده دخول المساعدات الى قطاع غزه
واعتقد ان النظام القائم
حاليا هو سيفشل لانه لا يقدم مساعدات
كافيه ولذلك يجب ان ننظر الى فتح معابر
اخرى لادخال المساعدات الى قطاع
غزه سؤال كبير ايضا يطرح في هذه الاثناء
فيما يتعلق بوصول المساعدات يرتبط بشمال
قطاع غزه الذي يحاول جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عزله تماما وفصله تماما عن
جنوب قطاع غزه الكثيرون يتحدثون هناك انه
حتى وان دخلت مساعدات فهي لا تصل الى
الشمال كيف يمكن التعامل مع هذا
الوضع
ل اسمعوني ان الوضع مروع جدا واصبح اكثر
صعوبه ان لم
يكن مستحيلا فيما يتعلق بالتحرك من الجنوب
الى الشمال نحن نطلب تقديم المساعدات الى
الشمال وهذا يمكن ان يتم فقط اذا ما كانت
تحركاتنا منسقه بطريقه مناسبه ما نسمعه
هنا هو ان الممر والمعبر مفتوح لكن هذا
الممر هو بشكل اساسي يستخدم للناس الذين
يذهبون من الشمال الى الجنوب ولم يستخدم
الى الان على الاقل على مدى الايام
القليله الماضيه لتقديم المساعدات من
الجنوب الى الشمال في قطاع غزه ولكن
موقفنا
ومناشدة ان يكون هناك تقديم مساعده للناس
اينما كانوا واذا ما كان الناس في الشمال
في مراكز الايواء يجب ان يتم تقديم
المساعده اليهم كما هو حال الباقين وفق
تقديرات ان تم ما يريده الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بان يفصل شمال عن بقيه قطاع
غزه عدد الذين سيتضررون من هكذا
خطوه
انا قلق
جدا بخصوص اماكن وجود المدنيين في الشمال
هناك تقدير بانهم ربما 300 الف وهناك قلق
لان الناس الان يامون الى المستشفيات
وعندما ننظر الى الوضع في الجنوب هناك
ايضا
كارثه ووضع مروع
جدا نحن نتحدث عن
سكان ارتفع عددهم بالضعف ممن يوون الى
مراكز الاواء وكن حتى الجنوب ثبت بانه
منطقه غير امنه الكثير من القصف جرى هناك
والكثيرون قتلوا في
الجنوب وتقديم المساعدات هناك
بالتالي اصبح اكثر صعوبه وتعقيدا بسبب
الحصار
وايضا لان عدد الشاحنات التي يسمح لها
بالدخول الى غزه عن طريق رفح عددها قليل
جدا هذا الواقع الذي تتحدث عنه بالتالي
كيف يمكن التعامل معه في ظل ان هذه الفئات
يجب انها تكون محميه وفق القانون الدولي
الانساني ما الذي يضمن حياتهم كيف يمكن
ضمان
ذلك
انت محقه تماما ولهذا السبب فان القانون
الانساني الدولي يجب ان يكون في صميم كل
مطالبنا وعملياتنا للمناصره ومنذ بدايه
الحرب قلنا ان هذه الحرب لا يمكن ان تشن
بدون قواعد والمدنيون
والمصابون يجب ان توفر لهم الحمايه اذا
كيف نحقق هذا مره اخرى نحن نؤمن بان
السبيل الوحيد امامنا الان هو يتمثل في
الدعوه لدنه انسانيه الناس في غزه بحاجه
ملحه الى وقف لاطلاق النار على اساس
انساني ونحن يجب ان ندعو الى زياده
المساعدات
للناس اينما كانوا وحيث ما حلوا اشرت في
سياق حديثك الى زيارتك الاخيره وهنا اسمح
لي ان اقتبس ما قلته قلت ان ال الذي قضيته
مع فريق الانر على الارض كان واحدا من
اكثر الايام حزنا في مسيره الانسانيه
الممتده على مدار 30 عاما كان الجميع
يطلبون الماء والطعام بدلا من تواجد
الاطفال في المدارس للتعلم كانوا يطلبون
رشفه ماء ورغيف خبز لقد كان الامر مفجعا
فئه الاطفال هي من الفئه الاكثر تضررا في
هذه الحرب كيف ترى تاثير ذلك على
مستقبلهم
بالتاكيد كان هذا اكثر تجربه محزنه لي في
مهنتي هذه ورؤيه الناس كيف
يدفعون ويضغط بهم الى ظروف ليس فيها اي
احترام او كرامه وقد زرت بعض المدارس
ورايت
الطلاب الذين
هم في هذه المدارس لا يفعلون شيئا سوى
انهم يكابدون يوما بعد يوم من اجل الحصول
على الماء او رغيف خبز انا قلق جدا
بالتالي بشان مستقبل هؤلاء الاطفال ونعلم
ان غزه فيها عدد كبير من
الاطفال والان هم يمرون
بتجارب
عصيبه والكثيرون منهم شهدوا
صراعات في السابق ولكن ليس بهذا الحجم
والان هم الان في مراكز ايواء في اماكن
يجب ان يكونوا يلعبون فيها ويحلمون بشان
مستقبلهم ولكن الان اختزل الامر لهم لكي
يكون امرا متعلقا بالبقاء على قيد الحياه
على اساس يومي اذا فسوف
نفقد جيلا كاملا هنا في هذا الصدد فيما
يتعلق
بالتعليم السيد فيليب لازاريني المفوض
العام لوكاله غوث وتشغيل اللجين
الفلسطينيين الانرو شكرا جزيلا لك على هذا
الوقت ونشكرك على المشاركه معنا في الحديث
عن تقديرات للوضع الانساني في قطاع غزه
مشاهدينا شكر لكم على المتابعه الى
اللقاء